let's do it
yahoo cousin jd ultra carlos champ boy
all right now it's moving too fast
what's up everybody
how's it going
we are here
hello
gang
travel
hi from germany hello from america
how's it going
i think
there we go
i think the sound sounds good
howdy how do you
hello how is it going everyone
legit ff what's up marvelmate what's up
oh crap
something is my stream messing up
guys how's the stream on your end i know
we had some problems last week but we
but we fixed them last week how are we
doing there
all right people are saying audio is
quiet
crank that sucker up a little bit how's
this is this any better
um for everybody asking i don't you know
i don't know if we're gonna get
oh
a post credit scene for this i hope we
do i
like if if we're talking like what we
would like to see as far as post credit
scenes
like as far as they go
i really would love to see the watcher
in live action like i don't even need to
see
like
him interact i would love to see him
interact with dr strange
but i i don't need to see that i just
want to see him live action i want to
see jeffrey wright as the watcher and
then that's when you know things are
like
he's getting pretty serious
things going to get pretty serious
thank you sachin
kapakumar
[Music]
this is the final episode i see some
people i see some people asking hey
what's up forsaken how's it going
uh yeah i i this is the final episode
there was gonna be 10 but they cut
they cut one episode out that is going
to be in season two
so we'll have to wait for that
uh
star wars fanatic i gotta go with the
classic infinity gauntlet
i'm gonna go with the classic infinity
gauntlet one uh i think
i really like house of m
i don't know that's that's a tough one
i'm gonna go with one of those two i'm
gonna go with one of those two
uh but i uh
it's really hard like to choose comics
over
mcu because that's like
um
there's so much more to comics
you know there's so much there's a lot
more storytelling i feel
um
you don't have
a time
right you're not like trying to fit
everything within like a two hour time
period
um there's a there's a lot less to worry
about with comics that makes it more
story focused
um
and there's a lot about comics that i
really appreciate
and
they'll always
they'll always have
they'll always have a good place in my
heart for that real quick hello lego
plays
happy birthday
hope it's a good one
um
but then the mcu brings that all
to life it's kind of like it's kind of
like what if
i've had fun with the series and the
last few episodes have been really
really good
but to see things in live action like on
screen is like so different
it's so different it's so cool
like
you know it it's just
it's on another level
so
yeah
i don't i don't want to choose
because i i think you get a lot from
both of them
um but as far as an experience goes
man i don't know i i don't know i've
literally sat there and read comic
stories and like have been on the edge
of my seat
so
so i i don't know i
i think you get i think you get definite
i think you get
different things from them definitely do
definitely do
um i think the hawkeye series
is coming in november somebody asked
about
december isn't it coming in
i thought it was coming in
november it could be wrong i'm very
tired
very very very tired right now um
the watcher is going to intervene that's
kind of like the point of this episode
like what if the watcher
broke his oath broke his rules right
like
what happens then
why do you keep falling backrest it's
just uh i don't know if spiderman's
gonna reboot again i haven't heard
anything about that i would be so
surprised
if that happened
so surprised uh hawkeye is definitely a
series
uh i don't think there's going to be a
clip of the eternals yeah it is in
november thank you all for looking too
nasty nelson what's up
uh a cosmic wonder meet and greet
um i'm not against that i don't know
if there's enough people who want to
meet me
um
to do it and i don't know where i would
do that at we'd have to i might do like
an event one day
to where it's like to where i i
i rent out like a theater and do like an
exclusive
showing beforehand
of something like so if that if i can
like make that happen and if people want
to
come and meet me and watch a movie i
think we could like knock two things
like two birds with one stone right like
you can watch a cool movie and if you
feel like meeting me you can um
i'd love to meet all you guys so
i i'm definitely not opposed to that at
all mr anderson what is up
it's weird we have two
we have two mods in the chat today we
don't get that very often i think we've
only had it like one other time
oh no
my g field exploded
that's all right i salvaged it i
salvaged it
so i saw the question
blacksmith's forge do i think
toby is gonna die no way home
and
my answer is that is
if it happens
i'm gonna be pissed
you can't do
my boy like that toby is my favorite
toby's my favorite you can't do my boy
like that um
i don't think he's gonna die i hope not
i i think that would be
i think that would be really
uncool
really really uncool if john wants to do
let's test everything looks like
everything's running
well
yep sound sounds good
video looks good
i think we all gucci
it's good all right cool
yeah like i mean really like if
if
they decided to get rid of freaking if
they killed
toby maguire that would just be
the dumbest thing
the dumbest dumbest thing
but
yeah
it's possible for vietnamese last member
sinister six you know
shank was that your name
shank i think it's a possibility
and it's funny because i've like talked
to the people who normally tell me stuff
i'm like who is it they're like i don't
know i'm like
how do you not know
like how do you not know who the last
member is
seems kind of weird to me
um i i i hope we get
a connection to the mcu and post credits
in here
hey the ozlog thanks so much for the
super chat good job we get invited to
eternal premiere happy birthday to jorge
segovia
um thank you
and happy birthday
to jorge
uh
what if cosmic wonder was never born
uh none of you would be right here right
now
who knows what else would be happening
in your life but we wouldn't be right
here hello
i want to say aiden
blaze
uh
oh no i just lost your message
something about dc content
uh i am going to be producing dc content
you know it's funny like i started
i i when i originally started off i did
like dc star wars everything
and
the reason i stopped is because
warner brothers made it very hard to
post
clips
and
trailers
and
just like one time they copy right right
they hit me with a copyright
for a plot leak that i didn't use any
footage in
and i was just like okay like this is
like this is too much like i don't even
know if it's legal to do that now and i
pretty much told them that and they let
it go but the point is
they make it really hard
so
infinity shades what's up coming in
every week
let's go look like you've been working
out hey appreciate that um i have
i'm trying to lose a little bit weight i
used to be a
bodybuilder but then i got kind of hurt
so
we're trying to get back in it now um
yeah i mean i'm never gonna stop doing
marvel content
um
that's always gonna be pretty much a
daily thing but i am out in dc and i i
am adding star wars because i'm really
tight with disney now so it would be
like i got the star wars visions
interview with the uh
the producer and one of the vps over at
lucasfilm so i i would
i would like to think i'm going to get
more
um
disney keeps saying that i'm doing a
decent job at interviews so
yeah
so it'd be foolish not to cover star
wars plus i love star wars i love dc um
i love movies in general actually
everybody um
it's a little premature to announce this
but i am
i am going to be star i am going to
start making content on another channel
um it's a personal channel of mine
and it's gonna be
one it's gonna have like vlogs from like
premieres because i film everything um
so i'll film like what it's like
like red carpet all that stuff you know
anything i can film i'll film and then
i'm gonna start
doing reviews on movies not just marvel
movies but like all movies and i'm gonna
start doing like different style
videos
and this is gonna be on a personal
channel and that channel is actually
just called cosmic warren
and i started a while ago actually
and then i kind of stopped because i got
really busy let me see if i can bring it
up here i was doing like unboxings and
stuff
let's see
i was doing like unboxings and stuff
here it is right here
so if you guys want to go subscribe to
cosmic warren you can i'm going to start
producing uh
other movie content
other movie content on there i'll leave
it up here for a little bit for whoever
whoever uh wants to see that um yeah
it's gonna be
different types of videos and it's gonna
be about other other movies right
and shows like i watch squid game
because there was like a lot of hype
about it and uh i have thoughts on it
and i don't know who wants to hear them
but if people want to hear them you can
go subscribe
you can go subscribe to that channel
yeah i guess a link would be better
yeah i guess the link would be better uh
let me get rid of this
i see some people talking about did you
get to meet feige if so what was he like
i'm going to stop causing war now hey
thank you infinity shades uh i have not
met foggy yet
um i have been so close to him
the problem is so here's the problem
like on the red carpet like i've met
like shang chi i met like half the cast
but then when like sima liu showed up
so
like
um let me explain how this works so like
on the red carpet there's like
and this is why i want to do like the
vlogs right so you can all see this so
like for shangchi the red carpet there
was like three different lanes
and there was one for like that they
brought like
random fans
thank you for saying i think that's it
right you put in the chat so they
brought like random fans and they're
like stay here you can't move and like
they just were kind of like on the red
carpet and then eventually like the cast
would go up to them and like meet them
so marvel specifically chose specific
people like fans out there and they're
like hey
you can meet these people and then
there's another lane that's for people
like me
where we're on the red carpet we can
take pictures we can do all that stuff
but like we're not being like
interviewed by like
big press that's there and then there's
another lane
uh where it's like just literally just
the cast walks down like nobody from
nobody from like disney like internal
stuff like that blah blah blah it's like
literally just a cast so in the
beginning before like those two lanes
divide
that's where i met like dustin daniel
[ __ ] that's where i met um
like half the cast there um
and
shh
almost called seema liu xiangchi but you
know shang chi uh i was like two foot
away from at one point
but his bodyguard like that's the thing
like the bodyguards were like everywhere
um so like i met minger i met destin i
met ronnie chen um
i met uh sochi who's going to be playing
uh american chavez not changing
multiplayer's madness because they
didn't have like a lot of security
around them but similar had security so
i couldn't like go talk to him because
he was like everything was like blocked
off so
uh jd ultra thanks for the super chat
as the watcher made a promise the same
people the eternals promised too
so we'd like to see some maternals this
episode uh it's not i'm good we rick and
morty making appearance so
um in the in the comics the watcher
he doesn't report to celestials he
actually reports to other watchers in
the comics the watchers
um
are the oldest race in existence that's
left in the universe and basically
they say
like the the watchers as a group like as
a council say you can't interfere
um
now the watcher does interfere in the
comics and he kind of gets kicked out of
it but then eventually gets like pulled
back in
um so
i i i think that's kind of what it is i
think that's kind of what it is
and guys if y'all spam mr anderson
will like kick you out but he's not
afraid
just saying
um
is the episode out
let's look
nope
uh i you know i played marvel future
resolution a long time ago
um chiffon what is my favorite non-comic
book film oh that's a such that's such a
hard
hard
thing to answer a film that's like i've
always really really enjoyed and i
thought was like so like no one knows
about is a film called meet joe black
it's with brad pitt like a young brad
pitt and anthony hopkins
um
yeah and here and chase you know meet
joe black look at that and cole bush
look at that
uh i'm uh teen asking nelson no i don't
think the watchers are more powerful
than the celestials
yeah i don't i don't know why it's uh
lagging like it shouldn't be lagging all
my settings are right i think maybe
my internet
might be having oh you know what it's
windy
that might be affecting i live on top of
a mountain like the neighborhood i live
in it's like really high up in a
mountain
so sometimes we get a lot of wind
all right
all right all right all right
cool cool cool
um i can't
pee can i confirm andrew or toby being
dodge trains jim i can't
sorry
sorry sorry
yeah maybe it's just internet in general
uh nope haven't sorry gabs haven't heard
anything about miss marvel
um so guys there are bands and there are
timeouts if you spam uh
mr anderson
has
all the power to
do whatever he feels
[Laughter]
so there you go uh
what am i expecting what's up man how's
it going um
what am i expecting
i'm expecting the watcher to bring in
all these different strong characters
from the different universes were kind
of going to get like a guardians of the
universe type of thing
they will ultimately
they will ultimately
defeat ultron
but here's the deal
and i'm going to talk about this
probably not tomorrow but probably the
next day
there was a
leaked photo
and i i don't know if it's real or not i
got to do more i've been flying like the
past two days
so um
like the news for me has been like
spotty because i've been having to play
kind of catch up with everything so
but
there's a picture out there uh
that looks like it's from doctor strange
multiverse madness and it shows ultron
bots plus the direct reported
ultron bach bots
in
multiples of madness so i'm thinking
like if that's true which does seem to
be true
maybe ultron actually
affects some of these other universes or
the main mcu
um
and that's what i would like to see
happen
in the post-credits scene i would like
to see like the watcher go into the main
mcu
and like warn doctor strange and just be
like we kind of took care of it
but there are remnants everywhere like
they're ultron bots and like
you know a lot of stuff like that so
i'm curious how
in this episode
i'm curious how
they're gonna defeat him since he has
all the infinity stones
and i like
he can snap he's made out of vibranium
like
couldn't he just snap in his body would
be okay
um
uh i i'm just i'm curious as how that's
gonna work how are they gonna defeat him
um
yo bro uh
i i just say ultron actually um
i haven't been calling him either of the
two
uh i wanted to end
i wanted to end with
ultron or a remnant of ultron getting
away and going into the mz
that's what i want
i think this is the
ultron we deserved
the old term we should have got
and maybe they see that
and maybe they're like hey we should
bring ultron back in phase four and face
five blah blah blah blah blah blah
um
i think that would be really really cool
so
if i'm hoping for anything that's what
i'm hoping for i'm hoping
for
what if to kind of like
resurrect ultron
and then
he comes back
and then the post-credits scene i hope
is the watcher
like talking to our doctor strange or
something like that i i really think
there's so much potential here for a
post-credits scene
and i don't want it to be about season
two
i don't care about season two right now
like there's so much that's gonna happen
before season two it i don't even care
um
i want it to set up something
epic because i think we have a good
chance here
hey bradley what's up man thanks for
super chat bradley jones the watchers
team will be enough to stop ultron what
if kang shows up and he is the one to
put ultron to rest arcang that would be
pretty cool i don't know though um
i don't know i think the watcher might
have something above us up his sleeve
you know i mean he is a cosmic bean they
they are and they are very powerful and
we saw him go toe-to-toe with ultron
kind of he lost but like
i i think there's more power
behind the watcher
and still freaking that
that line that he drops you cannot
compute
what does he say i can't remember what
he said you know you can't compute the
strength of my will or something like
that i posted it let me see it's on my
twitter because i i love that line
that was like
that give me like chills line like it
was freaking that was crazy
uh it's right here hold on you cannot
compute the power of my will yeah that
was like
crazy hey kiddrick man what's up
do i think tony's death is an absolute
point no
um
because
it happened at different points in time
and i think
well i guess i can't say that because
christine doesn't die in the main mcu
but
in the other universe that's an absolute
point in time so
no i don't think
and i think you're referring to
new rock yeah new rockstars did a video
on it today i didn't watch it but the
but it struck me like the title struck
me i was like huh that's an interesting
concept but i don't think so
did anybody watch that video what did uh
what did eric boss say
or
if it wasn't him
what did what did uh
what did new rockstars have to say about
that um is the episode out i don't think
so
but you know what
we can go ahead and check
oh hold on infinity shade's coming back
in
thank you for that super chatter super
appreciate that and
they could defeat ultron by d dosing him
or feed him on xbox lives basically the
internet matching
nine year old fortnight player and
getting danced on oh man you know what
they should do something like that
because that would just be clever like
that would just be clever as hell
i
i think something clever like that would
be really really funny
but
sadly i think it's not gonna i mean it's
obviously not gonna be that right but
i'm just thinking about how many times
i've been freaking
killed by
nine-year-old freaking fortnite players
you know what i mean where it's just
like like i'm decent at fortnight like i
actually am decent at fortnight like i
can build really well blah blah blah
um and
like i'll like run through people and
the next thing you know it's like here
comes like these building boys and it's
just like they don't even stop moving
and they destroy me and it's just
it's crazy
um is iron man my favorite
mcu hero no thor is
thor is my favorite mcu hero
yeah i haven't played fortnite lately i
have been playing new world i actually
really like that game let's see how long
i like it for
um
i haven't been playing that much
that much video games lately um also
i've been traveling a lot
and i'm also very tired
and i will be doing a breakdown of this
don't you worry i did a breakdown last
time i know i know
um
i know some people wanted the breakdowns
i know i didn't do a few breakdowns for
what if um and to be honest like
i didn't like some of the episodes so i
didn't do breakdowns on them
to be perfectly honest some i didn't
like and i did do breakdowns on them but
uh like
this for what if like if something else
came out i i reported that just because
i felt like it was more important
if i felt
if i felt that
the
if i felt like what if truly had a
really really big impact on the mcu all
the way through i would have of course
did breakdowns every single time but i
didn't feel that way now i do
now i think
now i think some stuff is about to
happen i think i missed a super chat
gina st nelson what's up zombie wanda vs
ultron
i i mean that view that be the strat
right there right um
that would be super cool i wonder if
i wonder if
she because it's vision right
so it's like
you know it's like would she go would
she go ham would she realize that like
ultron kind of took over vision's
okay it's out
oh hold on i gotta get this super chat
do you know when what if season two come
out they haven't said anything yet um
angelo ski 2005. thank you for the super
chat they they unfortunately have not
said anything at all all right guys
what if the watcher broke his oath
there's an awesome picture of thor we
are starting in three
two
one
mr anderson will have the time as always
and here we
go just gonna go through this recap at
first of course
oh i forgot to do something oh no
[Music]
save
save
there we go
here we go
35 minutes long
space
the final frontier i'm just kidding
every time that's what i feel
time space
it says chadwick boseman is in this one
we're getting them again oh because
star-lord's in it right him is star-lord
isn't it
i i mean i wasn't ex i wasn't expecting
this to be a long episode they're all
around 35 minutes that's kind of what i
was expecting actually they're all
around 30 minutes i think this tightly
it might be the longest episode
uh ksbs i did work i did watch and
participate in the galactus event it was
really cool
also if you like g fuel use code cosmic
you get a discount
what if all right let's see just how it
starts it off let's go
and i'll try to be
bad truck
so this must be the same universe that
we saw from the first one
yeah so it's literally just like reverse
okay no offense but i don't want to
like i don't want to watch this right
now i love captain carter she's awesome
but i want to see the multiverse stuff
hurry up watch her show up
is that supposed to be
a truck
it is isn't it
doesn't really look like him
dude she's a super soldier
and you're break dancing
hey
you have been chosen that's dope
oh
star-lord t'challa
dude that is so dope
oh
oh what's happening
gamora
tony is he gonna die
yeah he is isaiah thanks for that super
chat
destroyer of thanos
wow
oh look it's the same it's the same
universe
what
eric stevens
wow
well that kind of ended up being nothing
huh
hello party thor odin son oh look ultron
bots
hahaha
ah
yo that got me
yo that got me
interesting what is happening
hey
of life as you know it
oh i forgot to show some of it i always
do that
thor's got a beer
multiverse
to save all of them
the guardians of the multiverse
that is dope
my lady jane needs me
look at that they're like in a void
between all the universes
dang look at that
ultra
he's a cosmic being now okay
of course you have to separate the body
from the stones
hahaha
they're all eating chinese food
after you get the stones you destroy
them
oh
the infinity crusher
just
i picked him that's so funny
get the stones
get it to gamora
can y'all hear my cat right now
what's up meowing
i love freaking
good luck and here we go
interesting
happily
oh
captain america and my universe
can you show her that site
what is this he killmonger is messing
with ultron
head
they don't trust him
thor i trust everybody
hey
doctor strange is not very good at a
toast
to the guardians of the multiverse
that's freaking dope
so thor's doing something thor just sent
out some lightning oh
wow he found him super fast
i excel at attracting unwanted attention
what is what is happening oh
there he is
pretty dope
a non-compliant spell oh
that's pretty sick
protection spell
that's epic
watcher
okay so the watchers just like in the
background
i know how to deal with this good
fifa las vegas
ah that's dope ultron's gonna do is he's
just gonna kill him right away no okay
good
i haven't heard that battle cry before
what is the watcher doing right now
oh
it won't last long
oh that's so cool look at all the
hammers
oh
that's so cool
dang
she's worthy oh maybe not no she just
grabbed onto it when he was recalling it
dang
dude that's pretty cool there's like a
ton of hammers
t'challa's
oh he got it
he got one of the stones
dude that's dope
dude
you stole my soul stone
he's pushed
oh zombies
[Laughter]
wow that's a lot of zombies
oh oh
is it her is she coming
is she here
come on zombie wanda
there it is oh here we go here we go
here we go
oh
that's different
oh what the frick
okay so she's in a different
universe okay they're different
universes now sweet all right destroy
the stone destroy it
what the hell oh
black widow
she's the touch
no worries caleb
welcome
so black widow is the only person alive
in this universe
and now she uh
she has company
old drugs there you wasting too much
time
oh thor knocked his arm off
it was that easy huh
killmonger got the stone that's not
gonna be good killmonger oh no it's on
the floor
maybe killmonger will redeem himself
somehow
oh that's pretty cool oh dang
i can destroy galaxies with a thot why
won't you die
did he just eat the stone
wait did doctor strange just eat the
stone even ultron said what
no the sun's still on the ground he ate
all of his blasts
red guardian shield
oh double shield action that's hilarious
oh
snap
that's cool
come on guys are you serious
he's just getting drilled by the shields
all right he's gonna be pissed and
something's gonna happen
oh they're actually like they're
actually getting him they're getting him
somebody just oh
why don't stop trying to get this oh did
aldrin get it nope
no did she slice him in half
oh he's
is he using the time stone
to rewind time what is happening
oh he got it
oh we got it
where's the watcher
like
oh he has a time stone too so he's kind
of immune where's the watcher
oh that's freaking dope
just let it out strange
let out schumacher just let it out
that's pretty crazy
oh
let it out strange
thank you
oh snap
oh
oh stop is this thing gonna
no way
is he done though
oh it's taking them whoa
it took them
oh
yeah to child it doesn't
look at that
guardians of the multiverse baby
but why would the stones be different
he has all of them now
brace yourselves for what
you're i mean the watcher has to come in
and fight now
yo
it's you
if i destroy you you all fall dang he
figured it out
get him strange
dude where's the watcher
their shields are breaking dang
their shields are down
ooh a bike though
oh and i ate oh
oh the ai
zo zola
huh
get them strange
come on widow
come on
oh strange is running out of fuel
widow's got the bow
that's pretty dope shot
i'm so confused as to what
peggy carter is doing
oh
the spells are
oh
right in the eye okay
the omniscient
cosmic entity ultron couldn't
wasn't aware that
that was about to happen
he yanked it out
oh he's in it
look he's in it he's in ultron
this body's occupied
[Music]
they're fighting inside
that's so cool
my objective is to end you
dang
oh was that really that simple
was it is that just it
so
but is it's all gonna take over now or
how
how is killmonger doing this
killmonger is like taking
the vibranium from him
and the style graves will not kill
monger is gonna be the freaking bad guy
but he doesn't have all of them
strange ain't having it
but he doesn't have all the stones
there's he only has five
or did he had did he have six
oh
there's zola
oh it's on his head there we go
but how is he doing this i don't
understand how is how is killmonger just
like magically taking
vibranium
and where's the watcher
we were never meant to win
separate the stones from the body
so oh
did he just
turn them to stone
oh he's putting them in a universe
and there's the watcher
i really want to know how killmonger
could just magically take the vibranium
i mean i know he's from condo and all
but like you don't have magical
vibranium powers
shh that's what that sh
your sacrifice
if that pocket dimension cracks if they
escape dang look at that
the entire multiverse owes you a debt of
gratitude
once you walk through that door
you will return to the exact moment you
left so they're never gonna know
oh
stephen
so they're never gonna know
you'd rather return to another time
dang she can't go back
but where does black widow go
because her world is where ultron came
from everybody died but her he's dead
now
and then there was one
i will go back there
day
i can't fix your world
that tour was a metaphor anyways
oh
the hell's happening
here it's steve rogers
fighting
captain marvel
with the loki
on a world that lost their widow that's
cool
there's fury
dang
oh
that's pretty cool
no way
dude that's dope
look at that
hey
i am the watcher
the multiverse every world every story
is my home including the live action
so show me a live action post credits
scene okay here we go i'm looking for
the post credit scene and i
do i okay we kind of have one i think
maybe
okay
found what the pirates were after
you might want to brace yourself
steve's old suit
okay
the hydra stomper
there's someone inside
who cares
that was dumb post credit scene
so it's literally so it was literally
just peggy going back oh come on
that's really disappointing
that's really disappointing post credit
scene
hello
i don't hear you or see you now i see
you
but i don't hear you
can't hear you
why are you mute
can you hear me
all right trying to get chris up in here
let's go to
audio settings
output
device
hello
hello there
hey that's me that's me right there
maybe
[Music]
that was a dumb post credit scene yeah
they're both credited with disappointing
horrible i don't care about what if
season two yeah i know that's what it
was like i mean
there were so much more they could be
doing with that
so i guess no immediate connection to
the mcu which is a shame because that
door was there
there's so much they could have done
oh for sure let me put your stream up
real quick
oh
man your thumbnail's popping warren yeah
that's a good one that i went with the
what if logo
oh you switched it up then from every
other one
[Laughter]
okay you can hear warren awesome we're
here let's let's chat cool
it's the opposite of venom
it is the opposite of that
there's a substance in the show
you have nothing in the post credits
okay isaiah richardson here loves the
post credit scene now we have steve
roger rogers and natasha back
i will again how and why disney settled
with scar show hoping
uh i mean
i get it if it is canon it is exciting
but i
here's my issue with with the multiverse
what's happening this is gonna be true
go ahead go ahead well so canon to a
multiverse means almost nothing in all
honest exactly what i was about
the multiverse demeans a lot a lot
not everything yeah
but a lot it just doesn't matter what
universe is this universe nine million
five hundred ninety seven were killed
that's the problem it's only one
universe right yeah
hey
frasier firefly people las vegas oh my
gosh i laughed so hard
i laughed so hard when the watcher was
trying to get thor's attention then he
picked him up and thor screamed i
laughed so
hard and i'm laughing thinking about it
great uh oh great time
yeah
yeah sorry isaiah i'm not i appreciate
super chat i see you say good point
there i wasn't trying to like crap on
like your excitement or anything
but
it's just that's how it is the
multiverse is kind of like
like to us the only thing that matters
is the sacred timeline which
everything branches from so maybe one
day if they cut all the branches and
there's some remnants of those branches
back
then we can see it right you know what i
mean so like
and that's why we were all desperately
waiting for connection a connection
right because it happened to you and it
didn't come which doesn't mean it won't
or it can't the watcher could still show
up at any time and be like hey yeah
here's some knowledge
but um it does it and that is always and
always will be the issue with the
multiverses it just doesn't really mean
anything unless it does tie into the
storyline we've been watching for the
last 20 years that was my whole problem
with this series i could get past that
it's animated
i could get past it being animated if
it meant something
and like it means something to me as
somebody who loves marvel content so i'm
not saying like oh it didn't mean
something to the people it didn't mean
anything to our universe now
what i hope happens
is because it was very clear that there
were old trunk bots in other universes
thor was fighting some
right and that's not the universe that
apocalypse black widow was in
no and there was a ton in that universe
so i'm
hoping
i'm hoping that there are remnants in
multiverse of madness because we did get
that leaked photo of ultron bots
that is supposedly concept art for
multiverse of madness so i'm hoping
there are remnants of that i'm hoping
i'm hoping that's what's up
mm-hmm uh that was what i was hoping the
post-credits scene would be was a
live-action watcher
meeting up with up to straight yeah
that's what we are universe yeah that's
what we were all talking about in the
beginning like
that seemed to be the consensus of
everybody like we want to watch your
live action
catboy234
you know
it is
the post-credits scene was touching i
just wish it was our main universe
thank you for that super chat i
appreciate it
killmonger thinking he did something
then straight up lost
that's funny he's like we're going to do
everything we're going to change
everything uh okay time out
because i was so confused i still am how
did killmonger get magical vibranium
powers
don't know right killmonger killmonger
has just always got to be this weird
this made me hate killmonger
yeah i don't know it's the same
killmonger from the episode right
yeah it's from the one where he killed
everybody well i guess i guess the whole
point was they needed him to be the
trophy holding
zola back
so i guess he got his
purpose
that's what he is or he's sitting there
reminds me of the orbs from like smash
bros this is what he's sitting in that's
funny oh yeah
right and he's like sitting in it now
it's all funny that's funny
but um
i don't know do you think there's
anything there
with doctor strange sitting there i
don't know when i saw his last little
smile i'm like he's gonna get bored of
sitting there eventually and break them
out and try to fix all the worlds
but
but then how does he get out of
the one that he's trapped in well i
guess with the stones
right because then they'd have all the
stones so they could do whatever they
want
that's a lot of responsibility to give
to somebody who has literally nothing
else going for him
but that's all
but
i can't remember if this was like real
or it's something that fans made up do
the stones only work in their respective
universes
no
i think that's something that happened
in the comics and people kept saying it
was real but it's never been the case in
right they didn't like say that in loki
no they didn't say that in loki they
didn't work outside of the universe
inside of a universe which is where the
tva was so they were relevant there
but nobody's ever said that they didn't
work in the and they didn't work in the
comments that way so everybody assumed
that that was the case but it doesn't
seem to have been the case
because the assumption is they went and
got the stones from different universes
in order to find thanos an end game
i don't
i don't uh
so here's a problem for me i think
i think this is very conflicting with
what if or with loki
conflicting with loki how tva like
controlling everything yeah like
well i think that this happens because
of loki
the events of what if are possible
because the tva is no longer watching
over everything i don't know
that's the way i would i would argue i
mean that's how i agree it wouldn't make
sense other ways otherwise i started off
thinking that way but
i'm also arguing
that ultron was powerful enough to
defeat the tva
like because if the tva shows up to get
ultron they're dead
you're not gonna go prune ultron you're
not gonna get the chance to do that
he's gonna kill you if you go after him
uh because the tva is not gonna have
protective doctor strange charms
i mean so that's like
i don't think they could have stopped
ultron if they tried
they would have needed the watcher and
the guardians of the multiverse which by
the way was pretty cool
but if the tva were involved
that entire multiverse where ultron
won would never have existed to begin
with
right so that entire branch
and and all of the branches we've been
watching
all would have been shut down the second
they were about to happen
this guy made a
a good point
and i guess i guess i guess that's why
loki's before it right but
it's fire thanks for super chat says in
a new phase of the mcu where the
multiverse is a huge part this was the
only series about the multiverse
that has no part
the only series about the multiverse is
number i mean
yeah no i agree with you chris i
definitely think it's possible because
loki i just
no no because the watcher watches over
the multiverse
i don't know i just feel like the whole
point of the tva was to make it so that
there only was one existing timeline and
the fact that in what if we jumped over
you know six seven eight different
timelines is showing that the tva isn't
shutting down those timelines because
the tva has crumbled into chaos because
of loki's
so where so if the tv existed all of
those all of those different universes
wouldn't exist
at all
because whatever the nexus event was
that created the universe not
necessarily the episodes would have been
shut down before
by the tva
well then you have a nice snapchat
thanks for joining us but then you have
to consider the watcher
watches over the multiverse
so when did he get that role the watch
was the oldest beans in time
well he
the whole time had to just watch so
whatever the tva is doing and everything
he's just watching it so he watched the
tva fall apart and as the multiverses
started to be created immediately
um
he's watching all that too i guess
he's been here the whole time
ludon thanks for super chat ultron is so
powerful but he lost from a virus he did
he did
which i'm like
well no i'm glad because i'm like how do
you lose with all your
they videos do a bad job the fighting
was no i thought it was really good i
actually really enjoyed the episode
um
i didn't enjoy the post credit
uh zx0 thanks for super chat honestly
the series was worse by far yeah it's
definitely my least favorite series so
far one division falcon winter soldier
loki they're all above it for me
um
rose rose
the stones didn't work in a dc comic
when darkseid had them ps killmonger
hacked the i head of ultron to
manipulate vibranium in the stones thank
you for answering that that makes more
sense thank you
jeez
that was bugging me because i was like
the heck he has magical vibranium powers
i mean i know he's from wakanda and all
but i don't think they give some magic
powers
and a dc comic with dark side at them i
i vaguely remember that crossover
so then people took that and they were
like oh the stones don't work out of
their respective universes well yeah
i heard a lot about that and i i kept
going like where are y'all hearing this
from because i thought people were
saying like
it was mentioned in loki or something
like that i was like i don't remember
that at all it's all over the comics
there are a few different comic story
lines where the stones only work in
their own timelines
um so people just assumed that that was
the case but it's never been the case in
the mcu ever
thank you rosa for that
you answered that that question i
appreciate that
because that was bugging me he hacked
the thing yeah that makes sense so i i
think um
i think there's some ultron bots left
somewhere
and so and that's the big question
because that's what ultron does right
ultron can jump his consciousness
anywhere across apparently in this one
the entire multiverse he's living in
they're fighting thor
so
that's the big question and and the
second question is does the
possible continuation of ultron lead
into the mcu or just season two of what
if
season two what if
because nothing that what if it's done
other than maybe teasing the possibility
of it has connected to the mcu yet
yeah
[Music]
i mean we have the big
uh i'm just gonna call it rumor
because i don't think it's confirmed
obviously because it's like
a rumor
all right it's possible somebody's
talking about it
right well no it was before what if that
peggy carter was going to
go into multiverse madness
oh right um
and you know every
like the producer
brad winterbomb
was like
yeah it is cannon to the mcu and that's
what we talked about though it's like
yeah but
it kind of doesn't mean anything with
the multiverse
right now if you told me it was canned
into the main mcu timeline i'd be like
oh
but the problem is mcu is now a
multiverse
with with universes that don't really
matter at all rose rose thank you for
that super chat again yes tony survived
so i don't think his death is an
absolute point unless you know later on
that university does that hey what's up
jack
uh
yeah i gotta have a chat soon hope all
is well same to you brother multiverse
has always been there kang made a sacred
timeline for his universe
they confirmed this in doctor strange
what are your thoughts i'm going to have
to rewatch that then
because that would make more sense to me
i was actually thinking that i was like
well what if the sacred timeline exists
within its own universe
and then there are other universes
outside of that
because
i'm i'm like wondering are timelines and
universes different now
you know what i mean
because there is a possibility that that
is actually how it is
it's it's it's complex it's very tricky
wordplay but that's how it could be
i hope that they do get a wrangle around
the idea of the multiverse and that it's
explained
not necessarily better but more clearly
in multiverse of madness because if this
is going to be the norm moving forward
is oh hey look we have multiverses and
secret wars and stuff
i think the mcu has a standard it has to
live up to
where it is a very
comprehensible
motion well they
they're smart they're not gonna no 100
and i trust them but where i'm sitting
right now i feel like the multiverse is
up for debate well as to what it
represents and what it stands for and i
don't think marvel should dabble in
letting us
argue about what it is whereas they
should just define
this is what it is they will and it
hasn't been defined yet they will i hope
they do they haven't told us on purpose
right right right right
and then i don't know they're waiting
they're gonna fail no but it's gonna get
even
and it's but it's gonna get even more
and and no way home
right they're not gonna fully answer it
they're gonna give us a little bit more
of a hint but um
multiverse of madness is when they
really bring it out uh park avenue
thanks for that super chat i feel like
the red is kind of rusty ending
um you know i didn't mind the la i
didn't mind the episode i actually
really liked the episode um the post
credit i've seen you know people like it
and that's great i'm glad you all like
it i feel like
it could have been more
um
but as far as like an ending i i i kind
of liked it but
if you don't like it so much i'm sorry
uh isaiah richardson jr another super
chat what up
thought and loki he remained said he was
tired and simply stopped watching the
multiverse to give it up to loki and
sylvia that's an explanation um
that could be but the the problem with
that is is the tva or the people who
really
monitored it he was kind of writing it
from my understanding he like wrote the
few he like wrote the future
and then they reached the point to where
he hadn't been passed before so he
didn't know the future because he didn't
write it uh mr spooky spare thanks so
much for that super chat yeah
zombie thanos didn't show up but zombie
wanda did
zombie wand dude
yeah see it's fire thanks for super chat
i think each universe has its timeline
and our universe the tva basically
controlled it also where did this gamora
come from apparently it came from a
timeline where she actually killed her
father and teamed up with that really
crazy cool tony stark who still wanted
to put bots around the universe
and didn't die and did it die that that
we saw yesterday yeah right exactly that
we saw at least um
maybe that was the episode that we
didn't see
no no no the episode we didn't see was
supposed to be a comedic episode
how was it yeah and and we will see it
in season two
okay yeah
they confirmed that so
yeah richard gregory freaking
dr strange
freaking was so cool and i'm hoping we
see something like that
a baddie and multiverse of madness like
holy like that was cool
mephisto confirmed
i think
i think i'm very curious to see
and it's kind of like this big wall
what happens post
multiverse of madness like what
direction is multiverse of madness
trying to bring us into
does it end with doctor strange kind of
having a handle on the multiverse does
the multiverse just completely explode
and that's really going to determine you
know the next few years of the mcu and i
don't know that we really know what's
going to be happening there and we won't
until the movie comes out
yeah
and i
cuz you also have to keep in mind that
you have
american chavez coming in
and she can open portals
so
like to other universes so
[Music]
i think it's going to get bigger um i
don't think
i don't think the
i don't think like because the tva is
like still there right like at the end
of loki it's like different
we don't know what that's about either
right
no but i don't think they're coming in a
lot of answers right
i don't think they're coming in anytime
soon and shutting down branch timelines
i'm actually now so there's multiple
tvas and different multiverses i think
so i i'm actually thinking now
that universes are different than
timeline branch timelines
because if if that's a possibility i
suppose because it because because tva
exists outside of time and outside of a
universe
where would the different tv exist so
it's definitely starting to get very
well it doesn't neces they don't
necessarily exist outside of a universe
they exist out of a timeline
which i guess is the same thing but not
could be the same thing but we don't
know right
but you can say they're
different right you can come out and say
oh timeline time is different than
universe
time you could time that exists within a
universe
and that's the problem that's been left
so arbitrary and open which like you
said might be by design so that the
thing is really go in
for multiverse of madness and and nail
it down and explain how it works yeah
but i really hope they do because if
they don't i just think it doesn't come
off
i don't want them to use the multiverse
as an excuse to just do whatever they
want all the time
well and that's that's
why i don't think they're not they don't
know what they're doing but as it
currently stands
it seems just like a scapegoat like oh
the multiverse explained it and i don't
want that to be the case i want them to
define the multiverse for us
yeah
uh joaquin fernandez my theory about the
multiverse madness is it's going to
bring in some stuff to the mcu
i know like venom x-men sonnyverse kind
of like how
cw did with its crisis yeah um
i think that's going to be the major
staple of multiverse madness as well
thank you for that super chat but i do
agree with you city chris
i don't think we're in that much danger
of that though because
i think we stick
to the sacred timeline
and
because if something affects the sacred
timeline like that affects it
right right who cares about the other
timelines like they might kind of care
right but it's but like when you have
doctor strange he's going to be like oh
the multiverse but you know but i still
live in this timeline you know what i
mean like
when they start pulling characters out
of different universes and bringing them
to the main mcu
you know well that affects something you
know if hayley atwell all of a sudden
just shows up and doctor strange the
multiverse of madness from what if not
saying that's going to happen but if
that were the case oh here's this
character enjoy
i just feel like it's just here it's
just
i think i don't personally i others
might i don't personally like that i
think there's going to be
[Music]
if i were marvel
i would have marvel oh okay well i'm
gonna do this
um i i would have it to where
if you intermingle people with your
camera dead or something
um i would make it to where
if you
intermingle people from universes
they're major repercussions
for the stability for the stability of
the multiverse
you know what i mean so like
that's how you keep it from getting out
of hand you establish a rule that's like
we can't just take people from this
universe and maybe they'll do it in
spider-man knowing home right with the
other spider-man they're like oh they
could they have to go back because you
know if they if if they're here for too
long the stability of the entire
multiversal fracture because they're not
supposed to exist here
i would do something like that and that
would keep it from
well hey let's go yeah
but at the same time
bring in the x-men
are they gonna do something and that's
the thing i needed to find rule is it
gonna be oh look here are these x-men
from a different universe but if haley
comes over it's gonna have this
crippling effect and it's gonna be up
and down and i just i need an
established law which like you said and
i personally agree and believe it will
be established i just don't like that it
hasn't been yet right right so okay
i have a question oh go ahead
i just have a super chat from jake
saying marvel hasn't been knowing what
they're doing since endgame creators and
higher ups have not been solid on time
travel thing maybe a mess question mark
no and i am posing that question jake
but i will stand with in marvel i trust
i do believe and i'm sure warren also
agrees
that they do have a plan
i think it just we're kind of being kept
in the dark and it's because of people
like warren who just spoil everything
i'm just kidding um oh no
but i think there is a master plan and
you have to remember phase four is a
building phase it really is like this
isn't oh let's jump into the next end
game we're years away from something
like that so they're going to explain
and it's going to happen i'm just
personally from where we're sitting
concerned and i don't think we really
have a reason to be what do you think
porn
i'm not concerned
i i think i don't care
about what producers and the writers and
all blah blah blah blah i don't really
care if they can't get it together i
have to trust him feige
feige's there yeah
oversees everything he's an executive
producer in every single thing he's the
president of marvel studios uh the
cco of marvel in its entirety uh
here's a really i i love this thought
rose
rose
and thank you for the super chat dr s
supreme strange is now a mini watcher of
a pocket universe reed richards son
makes those nathaniel richards he makes
those t he and agatha harkness takes
care of him in the comics you think the
watcher will pay for his interference i
do think he'll pay he pays for it in the
comics
they kick him out of their council but
he gets brought back in eventually at
some point in time i think multiverse of
madness will show us the repercussions
of the watcher interfering at least
that's what i i hope especially since
they do say this is canada to the mcu
and if you're gonna say that it better
actually mean something it's like oh
yeah it's canon like one of these very
very far off universes
it happened like cool no big that
doesn't matter
if it's cannon bring the watcher
and you know i asked jeffrey right
i personally asked jeffrey wright in the
press conference are we gonna see him
and
he didn't say no
he teased me right his final words to me
were i'll answer that with what if i'm
like well
that's what i'm asking you bro
uh
but i really do love that i really love
the nathaniel richards theory there
because and i i
my problem with nathaniel richards is
they're gonna have to nerf him so much
because he's just so freaking he's like
got he's an omega level mutant he he
makes galactus as puppet galactus dies
and he brings them back to life and he
freaking
he kills celestials and and you know
he's just he's like one of the strongest
characters ever
so
it's like the infinity gauntlet right in
the infinity
gauntlet comic
thanos didn't have to close his hand
to use the gauntlet right he just kind
of did it so in the mcu that was
they had to do that to nerf it he had to
close his hand to be able to use the
power of the stones that's why you get
that little
that little brief moment where dr
strange says don't let him close his
fist
so he can't use the power of the
gauntlet but in the comics he just uses
it over and over and over again and he
snaps everybody away and he doesn't get
hurt at all right so nathaniel richards
is gonna have to be nerfed hardcore but
i like that connection that you made
there uh rose thank you for that
uh
guys rate the episode let's go 1 out of
10 in the chat i want to see it i want
to see what everybody thinks i i feel
like in some pretty low numbers i feel
like i yeah i feel like i feel like
there's
there's mixed feelings about this one
definitely though so i think that's
because you know we had that expectation
of the connection to the mcu which just
isn't isn't there yet oh expectations
don't they just
ruin everything don't they ruin
everything and i'm part of the problem
aren't i
we are part of the problem
a lot of mixed numbers hey yeah whoa
whoa whoa let's see nine eight six eight
five two eight seven seven two nine
eight seven ten four nine seven eight
eight
years or months
i'm reading yours i'm gonna give you an
average from all those numbers of like
six
six point five yeah six point five
sounds good that's a two right there
yeah that's we got some twos
two nines probably six point five or
seven seven averages in here i think
seven is probably the average i've got
ten eight and five they're a lot happier
on my side of the stream
dang
negative a hundred out of ten
that's gonna throw off the average um
we'll call that an hour i think it's
6.57 average
nothing from these series on disney plus
seems all over the place confused
between people have they gone beyond
their reach no i think they're just
planting seeds there are plenty of
states and missing seeds and it's just
difficult for us because
it's not as simple as the good old days
and that's kind of crazy to think about
no we we have good old days in marvel
where there really was just a guy in a
cave making an iron man outfit and we're
just not there anymore you know we've
gone to new reaches and here's here's so
i i figured it out i figured out what
marvel's doing
and
you're hearing it here first this is
what this is what i believe marvel's
doing
i think
the
i think the where we're going to get
answers for stuff like this is in movies
i think right because they're not
decreasing the amount of movies they're
doing they're just adding disney plus
they're increasing the movies by like
one a year
and they're adding a lot of disney plush
shows in between like four a year
so many tens that's a lot that's a lot
and i think you're gonna get little tiny
things from these series
and then where we get our answers to
them and when they're and when we when
they address them
is in the movies
they're gonna back up and show us the
whole thing right so like loki
uh
we're gonna find out answers in
multiverse of madness right um
falcon and winter soldier we're gonna
get stuff in captain america four
right one division that's gonna be
multiverse madness right so we're
getting we're getting
a lot of i don't want to call it filler
content but that is almost what it is
but it does it is important they're
going to introduce new characters
right they're going to give them their
stories
what the series allow is time
time with very specific characters time
to set something up and set people up to
happen in the movies
so keep in mind marvel's not changing
the importance of the movies i just
think that the shows
although definitely important might not
be as vital as series themselves
to the overall arc of the mcu
yeah i think in each episode i think in
each series we're going to get
things that do matter
but they're not going to be crazy crazy
crazy crazy
until we address it in the movies i
think that that's what i that's what i
think yeah setup.filler is a good way to
to think about that um like i said
filler's not the right word setup's a
good word
um
and like i said
the importance of the show is it gives
time to develop characters to to explore
different story arcs
that you can't take the time out in a
movie i personally have really enjoyed
all the disney plush shows this is my
least favorite so far but it's still a
fun time but holy crap did i love loki
holy crap that i love one division and
falcon winter soldier was fantastic as
well like i've i've really enjoyed them
like really have enjoyed them i think
it's great that they're adding all this
stuff i just i i still think that
they set up things that will only be
addressed in movies
i think
agreeing with pretty much everything
you're saying here
that they're they're approaching phase
four and the new era
you know of the mcu whatever we want to
call this
is not the infinity saga anymore with a
different approach as well and using the
disney plus series to do that you know
in in
the phase one
it was really straightforward and stand
up it was here's iron man here's captain
america here's four they have individual
individual movies and they're going to
connect
and i feel like there is this this
behavior that we expect from marvel as
fans
that everything connects everything has
these cool little post trailers and
hidden easter eggs and they haven't
quite given that to us in this where you
know we haven't seen the repercussions
of one division yet with white vision
and
and her becoming this guardian
and then they've left it they've gone
off to something completely different
with loki because think about it
exactly right so whereas a fan base
extremely spread out with falcon loki
and wanda having zero actual connection
to each other yet right you know no
hidden easter egg or post credit scene
in loki where loki goes to the scarlet
witch and says we need your help or you
know which is very classic phase one and
phase two mcu and that's kind of what we
as fans to this gigantic conglomerate
are conditioned to so we're feeling like
oh no marvel's falling apart and it's
not the case they have a different
approach because they've gotten bigger
they've gotten more widespread we have
cosmic entities we have earthly bound
entities we have cosplay
all of these different things happening
and they will connect eventually years
and years down the road but right now
we're just so far out
the individual pieces aren't even near
to the same page and it is difficult and
and you've nailed it on the head with
the movies the post-credits scenes from
the movies the little details and
intimate moments from the movies are
going to be the real bridges yep for all
of that yep real quick
rosie thank you so much she said i'm
going to miss these live watch parties i
say 10 out of 10 because you make it way
more fun thanks man love you and chris
and neo and everybody i don't know who
neo is neo is mr anderson
oh
yes
and we love you
oh i get it mr anderson got it okay uh
thank you rosie so much thanks for all
the super chats tonight i really
appreciate it hope to see you next time
uh hari
jiffer prasanth which universe did
watcher took nat uh i one that we the
the one from uh episode three
where the avengers died
uh they lost
they lost the hulk natasha
uh iron man
iron man uh clint
and thor
and then steve was there and captain
marvel was called and loki tried to take
over the world but
uh he failed
so that was pretty cool i just wish like
it meant something
and that and that brings us back to the
the original you know issue is
it doesn't really until the multiverse
is defined for yeah so i have a q oops
sorry i was just saying i hope we get
you know the secret wars and we can see
some of these characters meeting again
and that would give it relevance you
know if two or three years from now it
is secret wars time and we have god
emperor doom there and yeah now all of
these characters
do actually end up making an appearance
in secret wars and they recognize each
other right
and it's like hey i know you from that
fight with voltron you know that'd be
cool that'd be really cool for them to
do and that's something marvel is
capable of well definitely could do well
they don't remember
remember
they don't remember imagine they
remember no
you don't think
i didn't get that they didn't remember
that's what i said nobody would know i
got nobody would know what happened i
think they would remember
well because he's like you're going to
be returned to the exact same place at
the exact same time
yeah they went back to where they were i
feel like they get to remember what
happened though well maybe i hope so
because i'd be dumb i took away that
they remember just nobody else was gonna
know because how could they right
um all right so question i was actually
thinking about this
yesterday
today
um
i didn't personally like
venom let there be carnage
um i like
andy serkis i like
tom hardy as venom
i i would like to see
more venom
but i didn't like venom let there be
carnage and i had the thought
that they should reboot it
but then i thought they can't
because it's connected so much
and then i thought did marvel screw that
up
for movies
like comic book movies because like
we expect everything to be connected now
so if marvel wanted to go back and
reboot something
they can't
without using the cop out of oh it's
just different multiverse which is but
you can't do that right they can't do
that
you you can't marvel studios can't make
an mcu
film that's one off because it'll just
be
so weird
and nobody will like it and everything
no one will like it but everyone will
think
it's in the same universe
you know what i'm saying that they
they can't
i mean i guess you could now the
multiverse say like oh this movie exists
in this pocket universe but then people
will be like what if like okay who cares
it's stupid right right and we'll all
theorize talk about oh it's going to
connect and we're going to have 12
venoms right and they're going to be
like nope no it's not and then it never
comes to fruition and it's just kind of
like
oh you feel empty right so like did
marvel kind of ruin that like because
like think about how many batman's
there's been
well
exactly and and now they're connecting
all those and it's
we're getting into some very dangerous
precedence here right but you can still
but there was never an established
universe for dc
until now until now
but they're not every batman movie they
make moving on is going to be a
possibility of connecting
right but they have not established like
one secret timeline right so it's like
literally anything is up for grabs but
and they've done like they did the
justice league and all that but then
they did joker that's off and we like
it's okay
because
they've haven't established something
failure is gonna come back and help them
actually help them maybe that's what
they've been holding on to maybe they'd
be like yeah marvel's wrong marvel's run
we're gonna swoop in now again i go back
to i have full faith in kevin feige yes
yes yes but and and this is and this
doesn't matter i like that it's
connected i'm not i don't want it to
come off like that because i definitely
like that it's connected i just don't
think marvel could do something that's
not connected and get away with it
anymore
no i just based off of the fan base and
i don't even think marvel fans are
really that toxic let's talk about star
wars fans right they're crazy um it's a
joke guys calm down um
oh no everybody go after chris
um but no you're not wrong the fans have
an expectation
and marvel has a duty
to realize that expectation and you're
100 right if marvel came out tomorrow
morning and announced hey guys we're
making a new iron man movie but it's not
actually going to connect to the mcu
it's just going to be a new story a
different continuation and it'll just be
a movie about iron man it's a solo film
universe right you can't you can do that
it's done that option is gone right
because fans will be disappointed in it
regardless of what you do exactly so
unless after phase seven
they call it the ultimate phase and they
move on and just start completely over
with multiverse 2.0 and they create a
new sacred timeline and nothing that
happened in the original marvel
has anything to do with this and we're
starting over
this is the direction they've chosen and
you're 100 right they are they are in it
right they can't
like no going back no there is no going
back like we like
you
um dc can kill batman and make another
batman
oh a billion times marvel killed iron
man every time marvel killed iron and
there's one iron man you're right
and you try to throw me a tom cruise
iron man other than maybe a two second
cameo i'm going to be pissed right like
exactly
right so
i just had that thought the other day i
was like marvel can't do that like it's
almost like the only way out of it
is for marvel to sell
or for disney to sell marvel to you and
me
let's do it
you won't start over
cowards i can't afford it
tina you know what i mean like if disney
decides one day hey we've done
everything we can with marvel
and they sell it to i don't know who
and they start over and do their own
thing like with the fox universe get
sold over to marvel and they're starting
over that's the only way you could
refresh and start over marvel but that's
still you're still gonna be faced with
the same issue
everybody knows the previous that's that
yeah 2000 thanks super chat episode they
cut must have been gamora and tony that
survived i wonder why they did that that
makes sense because everybody else was
taken from an episode that we saw so the
gamora and tony one must have been the
one cut only one i don't know
uh i don't know why they cut that
but i heard all i want from marvel oh
god sorry
i was gonna say i heard that
we were gonna get
we were go i heard we were going to get
that in season two but
now
that doesn't make if it was from that
episode it wouldn't make sense to show
that now so
yes mr anderson go convince marvel just
to sign everything over anybody can get
it done it's you
and you can you can mod for all the
all the uh
movies
i don't know how that would work but
we'll let you do it
yeah what you're saying here movement is
um
100 what i i think all i want from
marvel is
defined
multiversal laws that all movies and
shows have to follow this episode showed
us pocket realities and whatnot just
confusing over the line and honestly
anticlimactic and that is what is going
to be the case in marvel until they do
define those laws right and they will
they will define those laws guys i just
hope that they stick to that you know
they don't want to bring oh here's the
x-men and here's how we got them a
deadpool came from this universe and
that's fine but
i want it to be
it's got to be and it's it's sad to use
the word for marvel at this point
near perfect
it just has to be working
and that's the case and we keep going
back to that like we trust and disney we
trust they're going to do a good job and
fight what we trust
they've got they've got to they've got
to nail it
somebody made a good point let me find
it jeremy kelly they can have different
characters taking the mantles of the
heroes like how captain america is gone
now we have a new captain america and
yes
you can
but it's still stuck in the same
universe and i'm not saying it's a bad
thing again this was just a thought i
had and i was just kind of like did
marvel screw themselves i think my
answer is no
i personally love the connected universe
and i actually think it would be cool
for the
like i think it would be cool if robert
pattinson's batman was like there was
another one you know like
christian bale like he did this and now
you know it'd be kind of cool to like
draw back but at the same time
they've changed
batman's stories and told them
differently
but kept the same core his parents get
killed et cetera et cetera
and like look at look at the batman
coming out year two of him being batman
and i think that's so cool and you don't
really
you can't really redo the origin that
way which like the origins all kind of
stay the same but they're told in
different ways but again i
i don't think it's a bad thing for
marvel i think they
i think they have their formula and i
think now that they're adding to it
and and hitting us with some curveballs
and i think we're not ready for what's
coming i think
we have nothing to fear
the only thing i do say is that
like your super chat said like you said
without the find rules
i don't
care i feel cheated right you feel
cheated or it doesn't feel relevant it's
that's that's that's the way to put that
it's not that i don't care it just
doesn't seem relevant
so like
yeah
tina s nelson do you think the tba's go
going to go after deadpool i i hope that
we get some funny montage of deadpool
fighting off a crap ton of tva members
and then he's like after killing them
all
i ended up here in the mcu
i'm still waiting for for um
my my perfect plot for deadpool entering
the mcu to take place and it won't and
it says that but it's the perfect king
1.5
yep lion king one and a half but with
deadpool so they'll call it deadpool one
and a half
and he was behind the scenes in avengers
end game causing all sorts of problems
i guess it would have to be
two and a half though right because two
would have already i guess it would have
to be two and a half right and then
three is him in the mcu that's right
that would be glorious that full time
would be so much fun to watch for me i
would have such a blast with that it
doesn't even have to be that long
yeah
are we going to do a live breakdown i do
not believe so oh not live i mean we're
just chatting right now we're not going
to go through frame by frame and i'm
super tired so i'm about to
yeah i i just landed i've had a very
long last 10 days
i flew to florida i flew to california i
landed
i flew back to florida did a bunch of
stuff there
worked there just got back home today
warren just got back home yesterday so
we're a little out of it i'm tired
we're here and we're having a good
conversation i'm tired and i don't know
when the breakdown's gonna come out
tomorrow but you know what it's coming
it'll be there and you guys are all
going to go comment and like and say hmm
let's see if you're here at this white
watch party
at this point comment
if you're here at this live watch party
go and watch warren or my video tomorrow
you have to put in the comments section
hashtag cosmic bros do it cosmetics bros
which hashtag cosmic that's a future
channel we're gonna look for that
okay so everybody who's here there's a
thousand of you on both channels about
thank you for the super chat am i going
to any world premieres yes yesterday i
got invited to the eternals world
premiere that is the 18th of this month
and that'll be i'm gonna i'm gonna try
to hug angela julie
her bodyguards will shoot me before i
get that close but
i won't be there guys
yeah unfortunately marvel
seemed to be at capacity and
i got one of the last invites but i
didn't get a plus one hey i'm seeing
cosmic bros on the chat
oh bro dude
i who did i freaking sarah chris i was
like i'm gonna be on this red car carpet
with angelina jolie she's like yeah i'm
like okay shut the hell up how do you
it's angelina angelina julie i don't
like her well she doesn't like you and i
care about her
right it's just kind of like
angelina jolie has to be one of the
i don't know where exactly but top 10
actress
or actor legends of all she's yeah of
all time yeah all the time for sure top
ten no questions
then all over the place we got a tired
cosmic we got a few tired cosmic bros
we got two right here
yeah right now i'm a tired killsman bro
um
it's just so funny how some people could
be so jaded like that it's like bro
you wish you were her
right how are you
bad mouth angelina jolie like when you
get to a level of fame that your life is
just
you know something crazy i went on
a cruise with the lebran family for me
and they were there and fine blah blah
blah and we were talking about angelina
jolie couldn't go on a cruise no like
she would have to buy the whole she
would she could run it out completely
dude she should be no big deal to her at
all but she could let go on a cruise i
mean let's be honest she had has
probably her own
right that's like i mean but you see the
point though you can't you can't just do
normal things when you're those people
and you don't necessarily have to be a
fan of her or her work
but regardless i think you have to
appreciate her status she's done a lot
of great humanitarian stuff too like oh
i don't like her it's like
and you don't have to like her you know
you don't have to like her acting or her
style or her movies but you do have to i
think
appreciate and recognize her status as a
human being oh of course
her reach is just insane
i am angelina jolie
you do you mr anderson i wish you all
the success in the world
and becoming her yacht i really do it's
like in uh
step brothers the movie where the dad at
the end's like i wanted to be a dinosaur
so bad so i'd walk around pretending i
was a dinosaur and they just look at it
they're like you you're a human you'll
never be a dinosaur
[Music]
so i could bite your head off
right oh i remember that that was funny
apache helicopter
post credit scene that relates to season
two please reply i i believe there was i
think that's what that was i don't think
hayley atwell's captain carter is going
anywhere he'll be a staple character and
what if for a while and potentially in
the mcu one day um
i think that's exactly what that was was
a season two post credit scene oh yeah
for sure season two post credit scene
for sure for sure for sure uh
so i i've seen some people talk about
the spider-man knowing home premiere so
like chris and i went to the venom one
and it was very small um it was sweet
though it was a lot of fun
it was cooler because it was smaller but
uh like tom hardy wasn't there well
because you also have to realize
actually that like
the movie got delayed he was being a
little stingy with covington so that's
what i was gonna say they're still not
sure
if they're gonna do a big premiere for
spiderman at home
i feel like they have to
i guess so
i feel like this is the movie but you
know i do too and he makes some weird
decisions as a company i don't agree
with a lot of stuff so he does
and um but it but it's with marvel it's
the thing right so
yeah yeah
yeah oh some people ask me like why i
didn't like venom versus carnage because
i felt like it was
all over the place
and i have i can say something on that
since i uh seen it
um
and this is you know going exactly on
what i was just saying with sony is i
don't agree with a lot of what they do
and sony wants to be the mcu so badly
and i think they've finally gotten come
to some kind of agreement in conclusion
with marvel as we saw at the end
and i think this entire movie was just
to get to that like it was just here's a
whole movie here's what we're gonna do
we finally got the green light from from
marvel so let's just get there because
none of it mattered nothing that
happened to venom mattered that was my
problem with the air anymore that's my
problem with the movie and i don't want
to give any spoilers away but i was just
like at the end i was like okay so like
are we done
and then the post credit scene i'm like
okay we're done
right it's over
rather than introducing the character to
us who i will say that something that
happened in the movie was i do like the
movie more or not the movie venom and
tom hardy i liked the character more i
created a better relationship with them
but everything else that that movie did
was just here is a hour and a half of
you know venom and carnage and a weird
storyline that means nothing nothing
have fun and then here we are i think
sony was trying to get into the mcu
that's all they've wanted from the
beginning
um they seem to have that opportunity
now
and they they knew that it's a movie
that was existed for the post credit
scene and that's why i didn't like it i
think woody harrelson killed it and i
feel bad for the demeaning of that
um
tom hardy killed it
it was awesome a lot of that was fun but
the overall movie was just
yeah yeah
um
i actually really enjoyed the connection
between venom and um
eddie brock and then i and i enjoyed the
disconnect between carnage and cletus
because
you know like in the comics carnage is
he's like i'm carnage
and that's what we got here in the movie
it wasn't like
we're carnage
we're venom let's fight it wasn't like
that and again no i don't want to do
spoilers but um
to me
not enough fighting
it was a lot of it was like
i liked the development between eddie
brock and venom but i hated
the parts where venom was like in the
club
i'm like right why
why it's a it's like it's like a rom-com
is what i keep hearing people saying i'm
like that's so true
right between the two characters and
they end up coming back together at the
end and it's all okay yeah and like i
don't know i didn't have jokes were good
it was funny right i didn't have a
horrible experience watching it and i
didn't like hate the movie
i just wanted
more i just wanted more i just wanted
all the fighting
so switching topics enough a lot of
people are asking me if i've seen squid
game yes i have yes i really liked it
here is my
personal channel go subscribe to that
i'm doing a review about that soon um
it's like so hard to talk about things
when you're like trying to avoid
spoilers
like
i want to talk so much about venom
versus carnage
but like
because like
i can't like i'm literally trying to
think of a way to like phrase this and i
can't
without spoilers
and like i know a lot of people like in
india like they're not getting the movie
for like another two weeks or something
like that
right
hey that would be a good episode
abhishek
what if cosmic warren and cosmic chris
controlled the mcu
okay let's pitch that to them i want to
pitch that to disney
what are the youtubers randy what if
youtubers ran
i mean we could do it on our own
absolutely we could break our whole we
have to think about that
just to really think about that
i think carnage should have been in
venom three teenage you know some things
for super chat
well i think uh
i got something to say about venom and
carnage that isn't really a spoiler that
i think was a huge letdown and
you can agree with me
they wanted it to be rated r so bad oh
my gosh
but it wasn't and i'm sitting there like
pick a lane like if you aren't gonna do
a rated r movie do rated our movie if
you're not don't hold on and because of
that
no sorry go go the result of that was
shaky cameras and
carnage attacking something and then the
camera goes
you don't see it
and it wanted to be rated r so badly but
it wasn't so they cut it all out it was
like watching
a really bad movie that had been
censored
and it's just jumpy
and
i i hated that i really did hate that
it's like b rated r or don't be rated r
i'm gonna understand why you're not
rated r
but do it quick or don't i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna promote
freaking
pitch meeting right now and eddie's
career with him yoda
okay here it is right here guys okay
here it is here it is
this cracked me up
so much
this cracked me up so much so check this
out here's uh
here's what i think is just what
happened right here so he just goes
crazy right he escapes from prison and
along the way he kills a bunch of guards
he tears them apart he rips their spines
out and blood spurs pg-13 he throws some
guards off
chris because you probably couldn't hear
obviously
there's uh
ryan george in the pitch minutes like so
yeah carnage breaks out he tears people
on half and he like stabs him and he
rips their spine out and the guy's like
pg-13 he's like oh he grabs them and
throws them against the wall off screen
there you go looks like yeah
that's what it is
and and it was so frustrating
because it's like you want to or you
don't want to you know maybe not
everybody wants to see somebody's spine
get ripped out of their body but if
you're going to do it do it if you're
not don't
the first venom did a very decent job i
think of being a pg-13 but still giving
you that dark tone of venom
without making it like
rated armor somebody went through and it
was like hey let's do this and blood and
gore and swearing get deaf and sex and
but let's just cut all of that and
pretend like they saw it i know it's
just
piccolo it's carnage
right it should have been in my personal
opinion rated r i feel like sony if
if you're gonna go out
and be done with venom it should have
been rated r give him his little swan
song let him go full off let him fight
let him swear let there be blood
and call it well you know
and i understand why they didn't you
know i rated our movies are hard to kill
in the box office well and they did a
billion dollars for the first movie
and it was people they had a direction
and it was pg-13
but then just stick with with your
formula from the first one don't give me
all these weird cut scenes and weird
censorship i don't want that that was
very it gave me a headache like just not
getting the completion of everything
i i actually feel like they think
they could have
done more i feel like they actually
could have shown a little bit more
violence
oh for sure 100
but
but it goes back to that same he didn't
really care because it was all about the
post-credits scene
he's okay give him an hour and a half of
carnage and
and venom doing stuff and let's get at
it but i i didn't get as much carnage
versus venom that i wanted
yeah
one one really decent scene and it was
cool to see
the four of them fighting because it
really was the four of them yo dan's the
hero though
dan
as a normal person stepped up and was
like you ain't touching my fiance brosev
but guess what
dad's irrelevant because he lives in an
unacquitted universe
poor dan
well he'll still get to marry the girl
and eddie's out of the way now
maybe a rated r cut exists that is
possible the way it was edited it's very
possible that they just did it and then
they're like we'll release it later
uh
i hope so jeez because you know what i
feel like it would have been like if we
would have got
a suicide the suicide squad
venom
vs carnage that would have been crazy
cool
that would be cool
so yeah dan dan the normal man mr
anderson that's hilarious um
i don't know what their plan is for
venom three guys i
i actually heard a rumor that i actually
can't say
because sony will 100 know it was me
and that's a long story but i i talked
to
well i third party talked to a pr person
from sony
and uh
i was talking through a friend who's
known that person since seventh grade
and they asked him a bunch of questions
and then at the end they went do you
know the cosmic wonder and the guy's
like yeah i'm like well now i can't say
anything because they're obviously going
to know it was you told me all this
stuff
so poop
that's what he was doing he was checking
yeah right
for a second i thought the watch was
going to send a touch to the main mcu
timeline roberto soriano yeah i thought
something like that was going to happen
man
that would have been cool and a lot of
people in the chat at the time were i
hope natasha's coming back i'm like
i don't know and then it didn't happen
but
all right guys i'm tired
it's almost time
it's almost three in the morning we've
been traveling a lot
i think this was a good episode
um it's a shame a good rap
show
it's difficult yeah it's a [ __ ] that
shows more connections holy crap
hashtag
don't forget guys
don't forget
cosmic bros so
so yeah but anyways um
good good after chat
about that we
666 viewers mephisto confirmed
i'm trying to
somebody put in the chat when hawkeye
started it's like late november that's
when we're gonna be back here and um
well actually we'll probably be back
with some live streams before then
uh saturday
chris does them every saturday
i pop in sometimes
literally like behind me literally just
through that door that you see right
there because he's literally appears
we're just a door away we live in the
city at all times
oh
so
uh finish it off one you got this you
got this i'm summoning the energy i'm so
tired he's falling off on us
no warning there it is no i was waiting
for someone to put the chat there it is
thanks malek november 24th haka
there we go i knew the date sorry i
didn't realize you were waiting how dare
you sir i didn't oh
um
hey yeah if you guys like the new venom
awesome i'm glad you liked it and i
didn't hate the movie i thought it was a
good movie
i thought it was a good movie i didn't
think it was a great movie a fantastic
movie an awesome movie but that's a good
movie i enjoyed myself watching it and
if you
you liked it
don't let anybody try to convince you
otherwise except me
i like a lot of movies that people don't
like
it just is what it is
um but hey thank you to everybody thank
you to everybody who watched it's an
after party and you guys made that so
with your comments for real i appreciate
all the super chats all the normal chats
and i appreciate everybody who just sits
there and watches and
wants some entertainment or hopes for
entertainment whether you get that or
not from us
but mostly that's super but
now you guys are all awesome it's
awesome to to have
such a cool watch part in after party uh
don't forget to subscribe to chris over
at cosmic culture uh there's been
multiple links in the chat for that um
thank you to everybody wolf lalalosa i
know you've been talking a lot thank you
um everybody else that has been in here
love you guys uh we'll do more
live videos we won't wait
more than a month to uh
to come back and do these we won't wait
for hawkeye we'll uh
we'll come back we'll come back so what
was the uh old show we used to do called
i can't remember we had something
forgotten in there wonder dumb i don't
know something like that
yeah
maybe we'll just stop
yeah so all right guys
gonna get some sleep and then probably
do the breakdown in the morning as soon
as i wake up
and uh by that time paul from heavy
spoilers will have a million views
dude paul's freaking crushing it paul's
gonna blow up so hard
uh i really like paul we talk a lot off
uh
off of youtube but anyways look out for
that video in the morning and we'll see
you next time
again thank you everybody